toda la experiencia humana y realmente
la historia de la humanidad o de las
civilizaciones humanas nos dice que todo
parece caer hacia la tierra por ejemplo
las gotas de agua verdad no flotan si
son suficientemente grandes éstas caerán
no puede haber taxis que estén flotando
y todos caen no no sólo pasa con la
caída del agua sino que además de que
chocara contra la tierra se desbordara
por ejemplo si hay un canal y si cae en
el canal solo va a intentar ir como más
abajo en un nivel más cada vez más abajo
verdad si dejáramos caer un montón de
agujas si dejáramos crear un montón de
agujas solamente pues van a caer verdad
si tengo una aguja en reposo pues no va
a saltar automáticamente y va a empezar
a volar y a flotar y esto es una cosa
que es fundamental en todo lo que hemos
experimentado verdad bien y entonces
para la mayoría de las civilizaciones
humanas lo han aceptado como bueno tal y
como es
digamos pensarían bueno es obvio todo
de caer así es el universo y para pensar
de otra manera habría que estar muy loco
y por eso es que este hombre que voy a
mostrarles aquí este hombre de aquí este
seguramente ya lo conocen este señor es
isaac newton
newton este señor ha hecho muchas más
cosas de las que voy a describir en este
vídeo y quizás algunas de ellas no se
han ganado su verdadero sitio en la
historia de la humanidad y yo digo que
es una de las cinco mentes más
privilegiadas de toda la historia por lo
digo por lo tanto este tipo es bastante
fascinante y una de las grandes
incógnitas sobre el problema de la
gravedad era o al menos que se planteaba
que se planteaba newton era porque las
cosas tienen que caer es algo que
debemos suponer o asumir del universo
digo las cosas tienen que caer dicen
pero pero si se cuenta que fue realmente
inspirado por ver caer una manzana de un
árbol probablemente no sea verdad lo que
se ven en las caricaturas verdades en la
televisión aparece digamos que la
manzana le cae en la cabeza mientras
estaba durmiendo y entonces les dio la
idea no pero la mayoría de la gente veía
bueno quizás deberíamos ir poniendo un
dibujo déjenme pintar un árbol
aunque digamos aquí están estas ramitas
que hay aquí tenemos las ramitas no sé
vamos a ponerle algunas hojas
o así
digamos que aquí hay estas otras hojas y
vamos a pintar la manzana de la que
tanto se cree que newton
tenía como inspiración verdad digamos si
yo cortará esta rama
si yo corto esta rama entonces la
manzana tiene que caer
y si la mayoría de la gente digamos
pensaba que eso era un comportamiento
normal en el universo para isaac newton
al menos al menos un día se preguntó por
qué por qué ha caído la manzana y eso
para algunos es un gran ejemplo del
pensamiento adelantado a su tiempo
porque digamos es algo que por miles de
años o décadas o quizás cientos de años
los seres humanos lo tomaron por algo
obvio solo porque así era así era
siempre entonces él se hizo la pregunta
de por qué hay luz lo importante de
newton es por qué caían las cosas muy
bien eso era lo que lo que se preguntaba
ya esa pregunta le hizo entrar en una
espiral de razonamientos que dieron
forma a los conocimientos básicos de la
mecánica clásica que para la mayor parte
de las cosas seguimos digamos siguen
aplicando hasta el día de hoy de hecho
esto fue ajustado por este caballero que
tenemos aquí que es albert einstein y
fue ajustado hace
no mucho en la historia digamos fue hace
alrededor de 100 años pero para la
mayoría de los propósitos que vamos a
estar trabajando todas las matemáticas
que desarrollo newton
van a ser aplicables muy bien
y esto es porque vamos a estar
suponiendo que las cosas se están
moviendo digamos cerca de la superficie
del planeta y que no estamos ni si ni
tantito acerca de la velocidad de la luz
ok entonces vamos a poder utilizar todas
las matemáticas que el señor isaac
newton descubrió a partir de esta idea
de la manzana digamos y no sólo estaba
capacitado para este tipo de pensamiento
de que hay algo que debe ser trabajado
de alguno digamos
digamos con esta manzana de algún modo
debe haber algo actuando sobre esta
manzana para que pueda ser atraída hacia
la tierra pero lo que newton logró fue
formular
digamos una ley acerca de esta cosa que
está haciendo que la manzana caiga y que
como puedes imaginarte la cosa que isaac
newton creía que atrajo la manzana hacia
la tierra es la gravedad muy bien esla
grave de la gravedad y formuló una ley
digamos universal de la gravitación y en
ella dice que la fuerza o la fuerza
entre dos objetos y voy a ponerlo así en
realidad la fuerza la gravitación
universal debería ser una cantidad
vectorial pero la que vamos a ver aquí
es una cantidad escalar eso lo puedes
ver simplemente como la norma o la
magnitud del vector de la fuerza pero
para este vídeo vamos a escribirlo de
esta forma la magnitud de la fuerza
digamos del vector con la que se van a
traer los dos cuerpos el uno hacia el
otro va a ser igual a una constante que
le vamos a llamar la constante de la
gravitación universal y este en realidad
es un número muy pequeño eso es lo
importante de esta mayúscula que es un
número
pequeño
es un número muy pequeño y que va a
multiplicar al producto de las masas de
los dos cuerpos que están digamos siendo
atraídos el uno al otro muy bien y luego
vamos a tener que dividir entre la
distancia al cuadrado que hay entre
estos dos objetos entonces esta r es la
distancia la distancia entre los dos
objetos
entre los
dos objetos y si nosotros quisiéramos
escribir esta ley en términos
vectoriales aquí habría que multiplicar
por un vector que es digamos que aquí
tenemos los dos objetos este es el
vector pero tiene que ser de norma 1 así
que de magnitud 1 si quieres verlo de
esa forma por eso es que para no
meternos en más complicaciones
vamos a dejarlo simplemente en su forma
escalar muy bien
en particular si tomamos por ejemplo
aquí la masa de la tierra digamos que
está fuera la masa de la tierra entonces
si multiplicamos por g y dividimos entre
cuadradas simplemente por ejemplo puede
tomar la m1 como mi propia masa oa lo
mejor la masa de una aguja o quizás la
masa del taxi o quizás la masa de algún
otro planeta en realidad podemos poner
poner aquí la masa de cualquier otro
objeto para pensar en la fuerza
gravitatoria que hay entre la tierra y a
lo mejor en este momento debes estar
diciendo que la manera en la que definió
la gravedad isaac newton está esta
fórmula que nos da aquí está diciendo
que tenemos gravedad entre dos objetos
cuales cualesquiera ya lo mejor te
estarás diciendo mira estoy mirando a la
pantalla de mi computadora verdad estoy
viendo en mi computadora justo ahora así
que digamos vamos a dibujar una
computadora no sé yo por ejemplo aquí
tengo
algo así y aquí está la pantalla ok
bueno quizás no es la laptop más moderna
pero digamos que aquí está el teclado y
tú estarás diciendo oye yo estoy viendo
justamente ahorita mi computadora como
es que no estoy siendo atraído por la
pantalla de la computadora y es que como
es que mi cabeza no va volando hacia la
computadora o cómo es que la computadora
no va volando hacia mi cabeza y la
respuesta es que este número está que
este número es verdaderamente pequeño y
entonces aunque si hay una fuerza de
atracción entre tú y él y la computadora
en realidad esta fuerza se compensa por
la fricción que hay entre la computadora
y la mesa o la fricción que hay entre tú
y la silla y que esto es causada por la
fuerza o más bien bueno esto se
contrarresta con la fuerza que hay entre
ustedes dos entre la computadora y tu
cara muy bien
de hecho para hacer un poco más claros
vamos a escribir cuánto vale está está
vale
punto 67 x
como lo que está por 10 a la menos 11
newtons por metros sobre kilogramo al
cuadrado muy bien esto es lo que vale
esta constante y que como puedes darte
cuenta
es sumamente pequeño de hecho este de
bueno si si tú digas bueno estas
unidades son muy raras pero al final es
que si tú pones la g al multiplicar por
dos masas y dividir entre el radio al
cuadrado
y déjame ver
aquí en realidad me falta un cuadrado
ahí está si tú pones está multiplicas
por dos masas ahí quedarían kilogramos
cuadrados y el radio al cuadrado
quedaría como metro cuadrado entonces se
cancelarían con estos y simplemente la
fuerza me queda en newtons ok y esa es
justamente las unidades en las que vamos
a estar midiendo las fuerzas entonces
como puedes darte cuenta este es un
número supera su perpetuo por ejemplo
esto 10 a la menos once sería 0.000 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 esto es 10 a la menos 11 y
hay que multiplicarlo por 6.67 entonces
este número es sumamente pequeño si
multiplicamos a lo mejor por masas que
no son tan grandes entonces la fuerza va
a ser muy muy pequeña y eso hará que no
puedas ni siquiera tener mucha noción de
la aceleración que hay entre ellos y sin
embargo cuando empiezas a tomar masas
por ejemplo la masa de la
entonces esta fuerza empieza a ser
notable en otro caso a lo mejor puede
ser despreciable ahora la otra cuestión
es la siguiente si tú quieres saber en
particular cuál es la aceleración que
puede provocarse debido a a la fuerza de
atracción en hacia la tierra pues
simplemente podríamos multiplicar g por
la masa de la tierra por la distancia
que hay digamos de ti a la al centro de
la tierra o entre sus centros de masa y
que a lo mejor ya has visto en otros
vídeos a qué nos referimos con centro de
masa pero si nosotros multiplicamos
estos tres números o más bien
multiplicamos g por m2 y dividimos entre
re cuadrada esto nos va a dar un número
que generalmente celedón denota como g
minúscula muy bien g minúscula y esto es
digamos la aceleración que provoca la
fuerza de atracción hacia la tierra y
simplemente nos falta multiplicar por m
uno de hecho está g es muy conocida y
ésta es
la aceleración de 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado
ahora si nosotros nos tomamos por
ejemplo no sé mi masa en particular mi
masa
mi masa es de 70 kilogramos más o menos
ok y queda claro que es más sano es un
peso vamos a hacer un vídeo al respecto
de la diferencia que hay entre masa y
peso pero si yo tengo una masa de 70
kilogramos
yo puedo calcular cuál es la fuerza de
atracción que tengo hacia el centro de
la tierra entonces vamos a sacar mi
calculadora
vamos a ver entonces si yo multiplico 70
por 9.8 esto nos da 686 aquí van a ser
si aquí multiplicamos por 70 kilogramos
esto que es lo que nos va a dar esto nos
va a dar 686 686 kilogramos verdad metro
sobre segundo al cuadrado y esto
justamente es lo que nosotros conocemos
como newton verdad justamente estos
newtons que teníamos aquí esto es lo que
conocemos como newton y es un hombre
bastante adecuado debido a que este
señor es el padre de la mecánica digamos
entendida de esta forma verdad entonces
lo que tendremos son 686 newtons y esa
es la fuerza de atracción que hay entre
la tierra y mi cuerpo
ahora te voy a hacer una pregunta
bastante bastante interesante
ok digamos aquí tenemos a la tierra ahí
está la tierra y digamos que pues más o
menos yo soy no sé una especie de
partícula por aquí verdad digamos que yo
me encuentro ahí parado por el océano
índico no sé no sé dónde sé exactamente
por aquí pero digamos que yo soy esa
partícula este soy yo y ya sabemos que
la tierra me está atrayendo con una
fuerza de 686 newtons muy bien es la
fuerza de atracción ahora me pregunta
que te hago es la siguiente estoy yo
atrayendo a la fue a la tierra con
alguna fuerza y estoy atrayendo a la
tierra con una fuerza mayor o quizás
menor con la que ella me está trayendo a
mí y a lo mejor ya está a lo mejor tú tu
reacción más instintiva podría ser que
la tierra es tan grande la tierra es tan
grande que claramente la tierra me debe
estar atrayendo con una fuerza mucho
mayor con la que yo la estoy atrayendo
verdad desafortunadamente es
no es el caso digamos aquí la tierra
también está atrás bueno por aquí me
está atrayendo con una fuerza de 686
newtons pero yo también estoy atrayendo
a la tierra con la misma fuerza y eso me
hace sentir bastante bastante poderoso
verdad eso me hace sentir muy poderoso
ya lo mejor hay cosas como que no te
pueden estar quedando muy claras verdad
por ejemplo si yo tengo un edificio y a
lo mejor yo estoy yo estoy hasta arriba
del edificio y digamos que yo salto
verdad si yo salto del edificio yo sé
que voy a empezar a acelerar hacia abajo
verdad
digamos yo estoy acelerando y no uno
nunca de que a lo mejor la tierra se
acerque a uno y eso se puede explicar
muy bien por la siguiente ley que ya a
lo mejor has visto en otro vídeo que es
la segunda ley de newton que tenemos la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración muy bien en mi caso en mi
caso cuando yo estoy saltando del
edificio la fuerza ya dijimos que es de
686 newtons y mi masa dijimos que era de
70 kilogramos muy bien entonces si yo
quisiera despejar cuál es la aceleración
entonces esta misma aceleración con la
que voy a estar cayendo del edificio es
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
entonces si yo salto del edificio yo voy
a ir acelerando a esa digamos con ésta
a esta aceleración voy a acelerar con
este número pero yo no veo que la tierra
acelera hacia mí y eso es por la
siguiente razón la tierra también está o
más bien yo estoy ejerciendo la misma
fuerza verdad de 686 newtons los dos
tanto la tierra como yo nos ejercemos
exactamente la misma fuerza de atracción
sin embargo aquí la masa de la tierra es
un número gigantesco déjenme ponerle un
poco más abajo
686 newtons y entonces si consideramos
la masa de la tierra este es un número
enorme es un número enorme 15 no sabemos
cuál es de hecho sería bueno que lo
buscaras en wikipedia pero esto es un
número enorme la masa de la tierra si
nosotros queremos multiplicar o más bien
calcular la aceleración a la cual se
está atrayendo hacia mí se está moviendo
la tierra hacia mí pues al dividir este
número enorme digamos pasarlo dividiendo
del lado izquierdo
entonces me va a quedar un número
sumamente pequeño quiere decir que la
aceleración para que nos quede 686 tiene
que ser un número súper pequeño
tiene que ser un número súper pequeño y
que incluso podríamos pensar que es
despreciable así que notamos que yo
tengo una aceleración mientras que la
tierra tiene la tierra tiene una
aceleración también pero muy pequeña
quizás despreciable debido a nuestra
gran diferencia de masas